[تصفيق]
في كتابها الحكي ، كتبت Stormy دانيلز
أن أول مشاهدة لها لدونالد
ترامب في عام 2006 في جناحه بالفندق وكانت
بحيرة تاهو صادمة لترامب جاء
مرتديًا
بيجاما ونعالًا من الحرير الأسود تكتب ما الذي
تفعله ، صرخت اذهب ضع  بعض
الملابس المضحكة عليها تكتب أنه قد
تغير وكلاهما يمزحان حول شعره
وتقول إن الاثنين تحدثا عن العائلة ، ما الذي
ستفكر فيه زوجتك في وجودك هنا
معي.
بأي شكل من الأشكال لدينا غرف نوم منفصلة
، كتبت ترامب ثم أخرجت
صورة لميلانيا تحمل ابنها
بارون الذي كان يبلغ من العمر أربعة أشهر فقط في
ذلك الوقت وعندما خرجت دانيلز
من الحمام زعمت أن ترامب كان مستلقيًا
على السرير بملابسه الداخلية.  مارست الجنس
، ثم وصفت أعضائه التناسلية
بتفصيل كبير ، إن قضيبه مميز
بطريقة معينة ، فهي تكتب دليلاً على
قول محاميها مايكل أفيناتي إنها
سئمت من وصفها كاذبة من قبل أشخاص ترامب.
Ays في الليلة التي أعقبت
لقائها الجنسي مع ترامب ،
دعاها إلى نادٍ
حضرته لتجد بن روثليسبيرغر ، بطل دوري كرة القدم الأمريكية ، ترامب
يتحدث عن أن ترامب
اقترح في النهاية على روثليسبيرجر
اصطحابها إلى غرفتها بالفندق عند الباب.
السؤال
بينما كان يدفع برفق على بابها ، ماذا
عن قبلة ليلة سعيدة كنت
مرعوبًا ، تكتب أنني نادرًا ما مرعوب من
وقوفه في الخارج ولا يغادر بين الحين
والآخر كان يقرع وهو يلف مفاصل أصابعه
في صف منخفض على طول الباب ، يأتي
ويكرر في  صوت غنائي لن
أقول إنه غادر سي إن إن في النهاية
وتواصل مع روثليسبيرغر للتعليق الذي
لم نسمع به ، ولكن في يناير بعد ظهور
بعض التفاصيل
، قال وكيل روثليسبيرجر في مجلة In Touch إن
روثليسبيرغر كان على علم بذلك ولكن لم
يكن لديه نية لذلك  مخاطبة القصة التي
لم تتحدث فيها الرئيس ترامب عن
اسمها علنًا ولم تعترف بأي
محاولة جنسية ،
لكن المتحدثين باسمه ومحاميه
نفوا ذلك.  د حدث ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا
، يُزعم أن ترامب ودانيال التقيا
بعد أشهر في فندق بيفرلي هيلز كشفت أنها كانت
في غرفته بينما كان
الاثنان يشاهدان التلفزيون هيلاري
كلينتون كانت تتنافس
على ترشيح الحزب الديمقراطي ضد باراك
أوباما عندما أغلق المكالمة.  لقد كان غامرًا
بشأن هيلاري ، لقد أحببتها ، فقال إنها
ذكية جدًا يكتب دانيال سريعًا
ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان في
حملتي ترامب وكلينتون ولن تعرف أبدًا أن
هيلاري كاذبة تحب أن ترى من
هي كاذبة تكشف دانييل أيضًا أنها
كانت  تعرضت للاغتصاب عندما كانت طفلة ، كتبت أن الأمر
حدث مرارًا وتكرارًا من قبل رجل كان يعيش
بجوار إحدى صديقاتها ، كنت في التاسعة من
عمري ، كنت طفلة ، ثم لم أكن
تكتب أنه كان يغتصب فانيسا ، لذلك أضع
نفسي بينهما وأعرض
نفسي باستمرار  حتى أنه سيتركها وشأنها
يقول دانيال إن مستشار المدرسة
وصفها بالكاذبة عندما كشفت عن الاغتصاب